a lot of people in Boulder City are
sharing their concerns after
anti-semitic messages were found in the
area this week Flyers were scattered in
parks and throughout neighborhoods now
local officials are doing what they can
to find out who is responsible Sasha
Loftus is in Boulder City tonight
[Music]
I spoke with a woman who found one of
these anti-semitic flyers in her front
yard earlier this
year here at Boulder City say it's
startling to see something like this
happening here it's concerning Aaron
heard says she's still shaken up after
finding this flyer outside her Boulder
City home earlier this week I got
concerned and thought that I was being
targeted for something on it multiple
anti-semitic messages and symbols and it
turns out Aaron is one of several who
found things like these scattered
through the area these last several days
I don't know of a single religion or a
group that espouses hate in Boulder City
Boulder City mayor Joe Hardy tells me
his office received multiple reports of
hateful anti-semitic messages I think
it's deplorable when we attack somebody
because of their religion their race who
they are what they think mayor Hardy
says he's not just denouncing these
actions but will do everything possible
to prevent them from happening again it
usually feels feels like a very safe
place Aaron says she's happy to see
action being taken and hopes those
responsible will understand the toll
this has had
why somebody would want to instill fear
until a perfect stranger the mayor tells
me the city and Boulder City police are
investigating these incidents I also
reached out to the Anti-Defamation
League of Nevada they sent a statement
regarding this we have a look at that on
our website 8newsnow.com reporting in
Boulder City tonight social Loftus 8
News Now